[Musique]
4h30 du matin là où on vit la nuit nous
sommes sur le boulevard pie-ix dans
montréal nord
c'est ici dans cet immense entrepôt
fraîchement rénovée que les fruits et
légumes 250 producteurs québécois sont
vendus à leurs plus gros clients
c'est que yi dans la même journée arrive
le soir vers minuit et pendant la nuit
les transactions se feront pour
alimenter les marchés publics des
fruiteries des kiosques des restaurants
l'agriculteur michel sauriol ou un
espace qui lui coûte 40 mille dollars
pour toute la saison
c'était un habitué de l'ancienne place
des producteurs qui se trouvait depuis
60 ans au marché central
selon lui ce nouveau lieu ouvert en juin
est idéal pour les légumes parce qu'il
est réfrigéré les parfums de fonction on
a des températures de 10 12 degrés
celsius et on a aussi température de 2
degrés celsius
paul marchand les fruits sont plus frais
se conservent plus longtemps il offre
alors qu'il y ait nécessairement un
produit qui de belles qualités
certains trouvent même qu'il y fait trop
froid ce qui a au moins un avantage de
tenir éveillés pierre bastiais vend ses
légumes de 22h à 8h le matin six jours
sur sept depuis 37 ans c'est plus que
nuit blanche on travaille en dehors le
jour
quand on arrive à 11h jusqu'à 3-4 heures
ses clients sont fidèles à 80 pour ça
c'est toujours commandé d'avancé on
s'est pas mal lorsqu'on sent avant on
cueille en vain la journée mme en fin de
semaine ses plus forts quand même plus
au début de semaine 1 - c'est normal
comme si la fin de la saison et que des
restaurants sont aussi fermés en raison
de la pandémie
il y avait cette nuit-là trois fois
moins d'actions qu'une journée normale
d'été parmi les clients rencontrés
rita hébert qui vend des produits dans
un kiosque à laval parce que c'est
toujours le maintenant je connais tous
et vous êtes fait pour que ce matin là
ça dépasse qu'on a fait peut-être pour
4000 quelque chose demain
il y avait une autre habituée mylène n'a
donc eu un kiosque à l'est le blizzard
wouah toutes les nuits tout l'élu de
commentaire bello tout l'été mais sinon
toutes les années depuis que j'ai 16 ans
le nouvel espace est bien dit elle mais
un peu moins bien situées
j'appréhende beaucoup car plutôt vide
mais tant que ça revienne comme avant la
circulation c'est sûr ça va être l'enfer
il faut faire venir plus tôt encore mais
comme les autres ici elle fait son
travail dans le plaisir
fier aussi de vendre des produits locaux
en fin de semaine c'est tout à fait les
légumes d'automne contre pommes de terre
pâtes attiré les foules ou celle des
canneberges tout pour le tout c'est la
place à venir
malgré la pandémie une météo parfois
difficile et un déménagement
l'association des producteurs maraîchers
du québec est satisfaite de la saison
qui s'achève